V této kapitole prozkoumáme,
jak kvantové a klasické počítače
spolupracují na řešení jedné z nejdůležitějších výzev
ve vědě – přesném odhadování energie molekul a materiálů
Toho můžeme dosáhnout
pomocí quantum circuit,
která generuje vzorky stavů,
jež pak zpracujeme
a diagonalizujeme pomocí řady algoritmů
z této rodiny rutin,
jako jsou SQV a SKG – a na IBM Quantum Platform existuje celý kurz
věnovaný
jim a příbuzným metodám.
Pro naše účely v tomto videu
vysvětlení zkrátíme.
Ať už používáš SQV nebo SKG,
tvým cílem je najít vlastní vektory
a vlastní hodnoty hamiltonovy matice.
Tato matice může popisovat energii fyzikálního
nebo chemického systému, ale stejný framework
zvládne i mnoho jiných typů problémů,
jako je třeba logistika. Někdy
jsou tyto matice obrovské.
Takže zmenšit rozměry
matice při zachování důležitých
vlastností základního stavu
může být nesmírně cenné – to je cíl SQV.
Použijeme kvantový počítač k vygenerování užitečného podprostoru,
který obsahuje základní stav.
Pak můžeme promítnout naši hamiltonovu matici
do tohoto podprostoru – tím dostaneme
malou matici, kterou bude
mnohem snazší analyzovat
pomocí klasického vysokovýkonného výpočtu. Uděláme to
tak, že připravíme zkušební kvantový stav,
který se často nazývá ansatz,
a provedeme měření pro vzorkování tohoto ansatzu
ve výpočetní bázi. To nám dá
vzorkovaný podprostor ve výpočetní bázi.
Ale to, co skutečně chceme najít,
je skutečný základní stav. Co když
náš vzorkovaný podprostor neobsahoval
všechny potřebné složky?
Kdybychom zvolili lepší ansatz,
mohli bychom dostat lepší odhad základního stavu.
To nás přivádí k přístupu
vzorkované kvantové diagonalizace neboli SKUDY. Ve SKUDY
začínáme s ansatzem
jako předtím, ale pak aplikujeme quantum gates, které aproximují
časový vývoj fyzikálního systému.
Lze ukázat, že za několika předpokladů
to zaručuje překryv mezi časově vyvinutým
ansatzem a skutečným základním stavem.
Oba tyto algoritmy začínají s obrovskými
hamiltonovými maticemi. Fungují trochu jinak,
ale v obou případech kvantová část algoritmu vyprodukuje
podprostor, který nám umožní zmenšit naši matici,
přičemž doufáme, že zachováme klíčové vlastnosti základního stavu.
Kde tedy přichází ke slovu vysokovýkonné klasické výpočty?
Pro největší hamiltoniány
a pro nejpřesnější odhady základního stavu
mohou být i tyto promítnuté matice poměrně velké.
Proto využití výkonnějších klasických počítačů
nám může pomoct nejen
dosáhnout lepších výsledků,
ale také nám umožnit řešit větší problémy.
Abychom to vše propojili,
můžeme vzorkové algoritmy reprezentovat
jako kombinaci různých programovacích modelů
na sadě heterogenních zdrojů.
Například náš algoritmus můžeme reprezentovat
jako taskový workflow, kde budeme mít task
pro přípravu quantum circuit s překryvem
s naším cílovým stavem, za nímž následuje task
pro transpilaci, která vyžaduje jen klasické zdroje.
Dalším v pořadí bude task,
který pomocí primitiv spustí naši quantum circuit,
což samozřejmě
vyžaduje kvantové zdroje. A pak bude následovat task pro post-processing, který sám o sobě
může být paralelní diagonalizační algoritmus
běžící na více uzlech.
Navíc bychom mohli chtít spustit
jeden z těchto algoritmů mnohokrát,
zatímco měníme náš ansatz,
nebo je spustit zcela paralelně
s různými parametry.
Teď to celé dáme dohromady se SKUDY
v kódu. Tady jsou všechny naše soubory s tasky
a tady všechny naše soubory pro odesílání.
V mapovacím tasku připravujeme circuits.
V optimalizačním kroku spouštíme circuits tím nejlepším způsobem.
Ve výkonném tasku vzorkujeme bitové řetězce
ze stavu připraveného
naší ISA circuit.
Tu dostaneme z předchozího kroku
a provedeme post-processing.
Takže teď jsme připraveni odeslat náš
workflow.
Jak vidíš, vše běží v sekvenci
se závislostmi. Počkáme
na výsledky a pak si můžeme zkontrolovat výstupní soubory.
Tady je otevřený soubor z optimalizačního kroku,
kde máme naši ISA circuit.
A nakonec si zkontrolujeme naši end-to-j
-ration.
Z plánu.
A to je vše pro rychlou ukázku SKUDY workflow.
Veškerý kód bude dostupný v textové sekci
nebo v popisu níže.
A to je vše – teď jsme prošli několika
koncepty a příklady, které ti pomohou začít
se správou komplexních hybridních programů. Samozřejmě
tohle jen lehce škrábe povrch toho,
co všechno jde dělat s kombinací kvantových
a klasických zdrojů. Pro další prozkoumávání
koukni na dokumentaci a tutoriály
na IBM Quantum Platform
a určitě si prohlédni zdroje sdílené v textové sekci
nebo v popisu pro další nástroje
a software. Díky za sledování.
Jo.